ten thousand ships is the name of one of
the upcoming game of thrones prequels
and its main character is princess
nymeria
set one thousand years before the events
of game of thrones
the series tells the story of warrior
queen nymeria of nisar
was who led the rhoynar refugees from
essos to dorne
following their defeat by valyrian and
their 300 dragons
she is an ancestor of house martel and
house dane
and is seen as the founder of dorne as a
unified realm under martel rule
through the marriage of miriam martel to
king daron ii
nymeria is also an ancestor of house
targaryen
after the rohing was conquered by the
valyrian freehold
nymeria led the rhoynar to dorne where
she took lord morse martel of sanship as
her husband
after years of war and conquest house
nymeros martel established supremacy
over dorne
with nymeria ruling for well over two
decades as the princess of dorne
through nymeria's rule the dornish
adopted many rhoynish customs and laws
that remained to this day
princess nymeria was said to be
beautiful described by maester yandal as
strong-willed and
indomitable princess nymeria was said to
have cunning's skill and wisdom
although nymeria is remembered as a
warrior queen
and in songs is said to have been a
neither statement is true
nymeria is remembered as a warrior queen
although she actually was not a warrior
herself
in a sense of carrying and building
weapons she was considered a warrior for
being a cunning military strategist
and commander of armies comparable to
how in his later years timing lannister
was considered a dangerous war leader
without actually wielding his own sword
anymore
at the time of roy schwartz nymeria
ruled in nissan
where she had a palace the rhoynar once
lived in city-states along the royan
river
about a thousand years ago perhaps 700
years before the targaryen conquest
the rhoynar were on the verge of being
conquered by the expanding power of the
valyrian
freehold and its dragons during the
second spice war
prince gearing united the rhoynar
nobility in a grand alliance
against the valyrian freehold only
princess nymeria spoke against him
warning the other princess that they
could not win the war
however other princes shouted her down
and joined their strength to prince
gearing and even nymeria's own warriors
were eager to join his cause
despite her own reluctance nymeria found
herself
forced to join the great alliance the
war began a thousand years ago
when three dragon lords from valyrian
freehold
joined volantis in destroying the royal
sport sarhoy on the summer sea
the royal responded by uniting under
prince gehrin
the wonder of the roy who temporarily
made valyria tremble
garion led the rhoynish army of 250 000
which conquered cell horrors valizar and
volon theorists
where they defeated three dragons with
rhoynish water wizards
the alarmed volunteens sought help from
valyria itself
and the dragonlord's response sealed the
fate of the rhoynar
despite prince gehrin's initial success
against the freehold
the valyrians responded by sending 300
dragons against the rhoynar
garin's host was shattered and the
prince was captured
upriver at nysar princess nymeria
learned of garen's defeat and the
enslavement of her people
and she knew that her city evaded the
same fate
in response she gathered every ship that
remained upon the ruin
and filled them with as many women and
children as they could carry
most of the men had perished alongside
garen's host
roy and our women were trained to fight
as much as roy and our men
so nymeria's army was still a great
force
while legends often claimed that nymeria
commanded a fleet of ten thousand ships
beldecker argues in his history of the
roy schwartz that the number was
inflated
perhaps by tenfold while other
chroniclers
offer other numbers in truth no count
was ever made
maester yandel agrees that nymeria led a
great many ships
mostly rivercrafts skiffs pool boats
trading alleys fishing boats rafts and
pleasure barges
crammed with women children and old men
only one in ten will see worthy
beldecker exists nymeria led her ragged
fleet down the rhine
past ruined towns and fields of corpses
to avoid volantis and the dragonlords
nymeria chose an older channel
and emerged into the summer sea where
the city of sarhoy once stood
the following voyage was long and
terrible and more than a hundred ships
sank in the first storm they encountered
as many or more were taken by fear and
turned back
only to be captured by slavers sato
volantis
others fell behind or drifted away and
were never seen again
nymeria's fleet first limped to the
baseless isles
where they paused to take on fresh water
and provisions
only to be descended upon by local
pirate kings
the corsairs allowed the rhoynar to
settle on the isle of toads in exchange
for their ships and
30 virgins each year for each king as
tribute
although nymeria refused she took her
fleet to sea again
hoping to find refuge on south aureus
nymeria settled at zamitar while others
settled at yin
or founded new towns however the rhoynar
did not thrive
succumbing to disease the dangers of the
jungles attacks from slavers and the
native population
after two new towns were sacked by
slavers
and the rhoynar settled in yin vanished
nymeria summoned her people back to
their ships
and they set sail once again nymeria's
fleet wandered the southern seas for
three years the rhoynar attempted to
settle enough
where they were welcomed by its peaceful
people but they were soon driven off by
disease
in the summer isles the rhoynar settled
on the uninhabited so-called isle of
women
for more than two years the princes of
the isles refused to allow them to
settle
on larger islands fearing the wrath of
the freehold
however many soon starved for the island
was poorly soiled
and yielded little food and disease and
slavers took their toll
some of the rhoynar abandoned nymeria to
follow a priestess named
jerusaleka to return to their cities
along the ruin
only to be enslaved or slain by their
enemies
finally nymeria turned west and the
remnants of her fleet settled in the
deserts of dorne and westeros
the last siever the ships settled the
stepstones
or gave up themselves to slavers of the
free cities
nymeria and her ships finally made
landfall on the coast of dorne
near the mouth of the river greenblood
not far from the sandship
the ancient seat of house martell at the
time of nymeria's arrival dorne was a
poor land where a score of lords and
petty kings squirreled over rivers
wells and fertile water many view the
rhoynar as unwelcome invaders
who should be driven back into the sea
however lord morse martel of the sand
ships saw an opportunity in the rhoynar
and singers claim that lord martel also
lost his heart to a beautiful princess
with many trained in warfare the rhoynar
added their strength
to lord martel's own increasing his host
by tenfold
morse married nymeria and hundreds of
his knights squires and bannermen vet
roy and schwimmin
uniting the two people by blood the
rhoynar also brought considerable wealth
with them and their artisans and armored
skills were more far advanced than those
of their westerosi counterparts
to celebrate these unions and to ensure
that her people could not retreat to the
sea again
nymeria burned her fleet declaring her
wanderings to be at an end
although some of her people mourned the
loss of their ships
nymeria named her husband the prince of
dorne
declaring his dominion over all of dorne
however such supremacy was not an easy
feat
and years of war followed called
nymeria's war
the rhoynar and the martel subdued one
petty king after another
and no fewer than six kings were sent to
the wall to join the night's watch by
nymeria and her husband
soon only king york the fifth wiringwood
remained
the greatest of the dornish kings
nymeria and the martells battled against
wiringwood and his batterman for
nine years when her husband fell to
wyronwood's sword in the third battle of
the boneway
nymeria soon sole command of the martel
armies
two more years of battle followed but
nymeria eventually defeated yorick v
and he bent the knee to her ensuring
martel's supremacy
thereafter nymeria ruled from sunspear
the new seat of house martel
built around sanship as the princess of
dorne nymeria remained the unquestioned
the ruler of dorne
for almost 27 years dorne was
established a principality not a kingdom
for nymeria preferred the rhoynish style
of prince and princess
although she remarried twice to lord
allah of hellholt and cerda was dane of
starfall
her husband served only as counselors
and concerts
over the course of her long reign
nymeria survived a dozen
assassination attempts quelled two
rebellions
and threw back two invasions by the
storm king duran iii
and won by king raid and gardner of the
reach
as nymeria grew aged and infirm the
armies of house martel were commanded by
her heirs
when she at last died nymeria was
succeeded as princess of dorne by her
eldest daughter by lord morse martel
not by her only son by sir davos dane
for dorne had come to adopt many
of the laws and customs of the rhoynar
the dornish revered nymeria as the
founder of the realm
and her descendants in house martel
continued to rule dorne
through the present day as a result
nymeria actually became a common name in
dorne
comparable to how brandon is a very
common name in the north
after their founder brandon the builder
aubry martel himself
a direct descendant of nymeria warrior
queen of the rhoynar
named one of his own daughters nymeria
nymeria's fame also spread across
westeros
even young arya stark fascinated with
legends about this warrior queen
chose to name her direwolf nymeria
nymeria's life inspired the book's ten
thousand ships
and the loves of queen nymeria as well
as the upcoming game of thrones prequel
series ten thousand ships
legendary characters such as princess
nymeria
legendary battles such as 300 valyrian
dragons fighting rhoynar
and their water wizards as well as many
battles warrior queen and nymeria fought
in dorne
defeating six dornish kings all of that
and more this game of thrones break will
show 10
000 ships will bring thank you so much
for watching if you enjoyed this video
please give it a big thumbs up and i
hope to see you in the next one
peace